so I run a Halfacre vegetable farm in
Northern Wyoming I have 8050 foot by 2
and a half foot beds that grow two to
three crops a year so I have a lot of
weeds to deal with and a lot of crops to
deal with so in order to maintain all of
that I have to have systems to make it
go really really fast really really
efficiently and those same systems can
work in your 220 or 250q foot garden at
home so the first thing that I like to
do is go around the entire garden and
pull everything I consider to be a
perennial weed what that means is it's a
weed that has to be pulled out by the
tap rout with something like a weed hook
or a digging fork
and um especially things like grass
dandelions um you know some of these I
don't even know the names of because
I've just done it so many times I know
that I can't cultivate them bind weed
and
get him with a digging fork and with a
tap fork with a Tap Root intact and get
them in a bucket and get them out of the
garden because every one of these that
you pull now will not grow back and this
is how over time your garden becomes
weedless and a lot less work this is
brand new soil I just started growing in
it um in August and it's now May so it's
not even a year old so there's quite a
bit of these perennial weeds and you're
kind of going to have to figure out
which ones are perennial in your area
you could do some research with your
local Extension Agency but if you do
this a little bit every week you're
going to be in really good shape in a
year in two years it's going to be an
Immaculate Garden so this little bit of
effort on your hands and knees once in a
while is going to save you a ton of
bending over in the
future now another tip for keeping your
garden weedless is cultivating instead
of pulling by hand so using a tool like
this colinear hoe or a stirrup hoe or
any of the hoes that are available
there's a million different hoes out
there uh and I'm not making a joke there
that's just you know I have to use that
term uh the there's a million hoes out
there and um any of them will work you
know the idea is just getting the weeds
when they're really really small like
this is kind of past du this is too big
but um I'm really going for weeds that
are about the size of a quarter or or
smaller and they're much easier to
tackle that way so um this is much
easier than being on your hands and
knees all day um this greenhouse is 1600
square F feet your garden is probably
only 200 250 square ft if that this
takes me about a half an hour to cover
the entire Greenhouse with this
technique versus being on my hands and
knees if I was sitting there pulling
weeds like this you know I'd be in here
all day so it's way faster way less work
to cultivate your weeds instead of
pulling them by hand like I just did all
I got to do with this is get underneath
them the weeds will be turned upside
down and they will die in the Sun that
little root will die in the Sun and you
have to know your weeds too you know you
do this with hand lines it's not going
to work you have to do it with stuff
that will die in the sun really really
quickly but this saves you a truckload
of work and again this is really new
soil and new ground so there's a lot
more weeds in here than normal but over
time just becomes less and less work
another tip for keeping your garden
weedless is planting in perfectly
straight rows see these two beds of
carrots here I use a special tool to
draw a grid on the beds perfectly
straight end to endend it makes it
really easy to do that cultivating stuff
where I'm just running a hole up and
down these beds and all the weeds have
been turned over just like this and they
will die in the sun makes it go really
really fast also if you plant with
perfect plant spacing every single time
that's very consistent and in a grid
pattern like this cabbage you see here
you're going to have a lot easier time
getting that hole up and down the roads
and in between the plants and you have
access to every square inch of the bed
so you can kill all the weeds without
bending over perfect plant spacing every
time is a must for keeping your garden
weed free I have a whole another video
about that that I'll put right here
another tip is using this black stuff
called weed mat all around your garden
to stop weeds from growing in between
the outside and the inside of your
garden and all it does is it stops light
from hitting the plants they die over
time and water comes through so you
don't have big puddles but this is
really cheap you can buy it on you just
Google weed barrier and you'll be able
to put it all around the perimeter of
your garden so you have a nice barrier
from the outside where the seeds weed
seeds are coming up and blowing in and
it makes it a lot easier because you
have a lot less weeds growing right next
to all your plants that you want to
harvest
so the most important of all these tips
is doing a little bit of all of the
stuff that I mentioned every week doing
a little bit of consistent effort every
week is a lot better than doing it all
at once when you have giant bushes of
weeds in July if you just spend 15 10
minutes in your garden doing all of the
stuff that I talked about every week
it'll be a lot less painful event it'll
turn into five minutes or 2 minutes but
um as you get better at this and cons
consistently do it it's a lot easier to
manage this whole High tunnel or
caterpillar tunnel is brand new it took
me an hour and 45 minutes to do all the
things I mentioned in 1600 square feet
and that's because the perennials are
really bad in here still there's still a
lot of grass that I have to pull every
time I bet you by the end of the year
it'll take me a half an hour to do the
whole 1600 square ft and so I do this
every week on the farm uh on a half acre
of growing space which is a lot more
than 220 Square F feet and that's how we
keep the all the crops looking as good
as they are and the weeds as little as
they are so hope you enjoyed that and
I'll see you in the next
one
e
e for